Shantanu bought more apples than bananas
and he bought more bananas and
cantaloupes let a represent the number
of apples Shantanu bought let B
represent the number of bananas and
let's see represent the number of
cantaloupes let's compare the
expressions B plus C and a which
statement is correct
so is B plus C greater than a is it less
than a or are these two quantities equal
or is there not enough information to
tell so like always pause this video and
see if you can work through it on your
own and now I will work through it with
you alright so let's just write down the
information that they gave us they say
let a represent the number well that's
more straightforward a for Apple B for
banana C for cantaloupe here we have
more apples than bananas so a is greater
than B and then they also tell us he
bought more bananas and cantaloupes so B
is greater than C or we could rewrite
that as a is greater than B is greater
than C or we could write that as C is
less than B is less than a this is
essentially the information that they
give us so let's see which of these is
going to be true B plus C greater than a
B plus C greater than a B plus C less
than a so one thing that we can't rise
let's use let's let's let's try to plug
in some values some numbers to see if we
can get combinations that are
consistently in one of these buckets or
if they fall into multiple of these
choices and would say hey there's not
enough information to tell and general
this is a good strategy for things like
this where we were dealing with very
abstract quantities so let's make a
little table here so a B C and then I
can also figure out what B plus C is so
this is going to be a B C and this is B
plus C and we can compare that to a so
let's see a situation where let's see if
we can make let's see if we can make B
plus C greater than a so the
most have to be less than a so let's see
if C is C is 5 and B is 6 and let's make
a 7 so in this situation B plus C is
going to be equal to 11 so we're able to
find a situation where if B plus C are
close enough to a that B plus C is going
to be greater than a so we're able to
find this scenario let's see if we can
figure out a scenario where B plus C is
less than a well if well we could do the
same B plus C 6 5 we can make a bigger
than 6 plus 5 we can make a 12 and now
this is a situation so this first
situation we have B plus C is greater
than a the second situation right over
here you have B plus C is less than a
and so depending on what your a B and
C's are that meet these constraints and
notice both of these situations I meet
all the constraints where a is greater
than B is greater than C but it could be
either one of these so that immediately
tells us that there is not that there is
not enough information to tell now one
thing that we yeah there's there's just
not enough information to tell I can
even come up with a scenario where B
plus C is equal to a if it's six five
and eleven then B plus C is equal to a
so basically the information they gave
us any of these are actually possible so
there's not enough information to tell